(spacecraft zooming)
- The US has been flying this spacecraft
since 2010, called the x-37B.
It was recently loaded into a
Space X falcon heavy rocket,
and then blasted into space
on a super secret mission
right before the new year,
with very few details revealed
about where it's going,
how long it will be up there,
and what it'll be doing.
And that happened just two weeks
after China launched its
own mysterious space plane.
The classified nature of these missions
has fueled all kinds of speculation
about where these planes might be going
and whether they could
be used as space weapons.
So I called a few experts to learn more
about what they might actually be up to.
Here's what we know.
Although the US's x-37B looks a lot
like NASA's former space shuttle,
it's only about a quarter of the size.
It's autonomous, and it doesn't
require a crew of humans.
And then check this out.
When its missions are complete,
The x-37B deorbits and lands
back on Earth like an airplane.
- That's why the x-37 is
an amazing capability.
It's reusable, it's
returnable, it's refurbishable,
but it isn't an enormous
vehicle that's limited
by having to have humans on board.
- Because it's uncrewed,
the x-37B can stay in space
for years and Boeing, the
company that makes it,
says that since 2010, it
has completed six missions,
traveled 1.3 billion miles
and deployed for more
than 900 days straight.
So, what does the x-37B
do when it's in space?
The official answer is lots and lots
of classified experiments.
Take a look at this animation.
You can see the x-37B
flying with its doors open,
which enables it to
expose materials in space
and carry out all kinds
of different tests.
We do have a little bit of insight
into some of the experiments
it's done in the past.
For example, we know
that the x-37B has hosted
a power beaming system,
technology that could
one day enable satellites
to send solar power down to Earth.
And we also know it carried
an Air Force Academy satellite
into space before deploying it.
The experts I talked to
said it could also be used
to test materials for satellites
or space sensors in
various parts of space.
- This is national security related,
to counter the Russian,
Chinese capabilities
that are coming up.
- There are many, many experiments
and many things you
would wanna do in space
that frankly we would
not want peer competitors
to know about just as
they hide things from us.
- So let's talk about
some of the speculation,
like that the x-37B is
some kind of space bomber
or that it could be used to test weapons.
- There isn't a lot of common sense
behind trying to do
offensive weapons in space.
They sound great in science fiction,
but for many practical reasons
they don't make a lot of sense.
But no, there's absolutely no evidence
that x-37 has been doing
anything offensive in space.
- This painting unveiled by
the US Space Operations Command
also helped fuel
speculation that the x-37B
could be used to intercept
adversary satellites.
That's because amateur
space watchers said,
Hey, that futuristic space
vehicle they're depicting,
that looks a lot like the x-37B.
- It's plausible.
You can take out satellites by going close
and blinding it with lasers
or something like that.
It's all sorts of possibilities,
- But interfering with a
satellite is a little different
than actually scooping one out of the sky.
- So, it actually turns
out to be really difficult
to do an intercept of an
object in space from space
for the very simple reason
that when you are in orbit
around the Earth, you're traveling
at a very, very high
speed, a high velocity.
- After launching on its seventh mission,
the x-37B could be
heading deeper into space
than ever before.
And that's why this recent
launch is getting a lot of buzz.
Not only did it blast
off on a falcon heavy,
which Space X says is capable
of going as far as Mars,
but the Space Force dropped a
few hints in press releases,
saying that the vehicle will be operating
in new orbital regimes,
experimenting with space
domain awareness technologies,
and investigating radiation
effects to NASA materials.
That means the spacecraft
is probably going
beyond low Earth orbit where
it has operated before,
and it could potentially
even travel 22,000 miles out
to geosynchronous orbit.
- There are a lot of
really interesting orbits
that give you new capabilities
that cover different parts of the planet.
As an example, the Russians
have for many, many years
used a type of orbit
called a Molniya orbit,
which is a very high-inclination orbit.
So it takes 'em up to very high altitude
and then drops down to low altitude,
and they can use those orbits
to get more time over a
certain part of the Earth.
It gives you other advantages
that the Russians have utilized.
- The radiation clue in
Space Force's press release
could also suggest that the
x-37B will be spending time
exposing materials in the
Van Allen radiation belts,
which have been deemed deadly
to some types of materials.
- You have to take that into account
if you're going to establish
a satellite constellation
higher up.
- But of course, these professors say
these are just educated guesses,
since no one really knows
where the x-37B is heading.
Against the backdrop of all of this
is an intensifying space
race between superpowers,
and that includes growing competition
to develop and build more space planes.
The NASA-contracted
Sierra Space Dream Chaser
could potentially fly this year,
and while Russia hasn't made much progress
on its space planes in
recent decades, China has.
- We know that China has been
eagerly pursuing space planes
for quite some time.
- The US says Beijing has been
developing two space planes,
though details have been kept very secret
and they've been years
behind the US in flying them.
After one of them launched in
December, General Saltzman,
the chief of Space Operations
for the US Space Force
said that that plane and the x-37B
are some of the most-watched
objects in orbit right now.
And he said it is no
coincidence that China
is trying to match the US's
timing and capabilities.
(tense music)